- Ich habe den Wettbewerb der
jungen Architekten gewonnen!
- Selma, ich bin sehr stolz auf dich.
Du hast dich gegen
den Favoriten durchgesetzt.
Ich hab' mit deinem Chef gesprochen.
- Du hast mit meinem Chef gesprochen?
- Ja, diesem Herrn mit der tiefen Stimme.
Er meinte, der Zulassungsbescheid
für die Universität
wäre mit diesem Preis kein Problem.
Du kannst hier studieren, Selma.
Und ich werde einen Kredit bekommen
und meine eigene Praxis eröffnen.
- Du bekommst einen Kredit?
- Ja. Pepe bürgt für mich.
- Ach, plötzlich ist die Familie González
keine Schande mehr!
- Wir bauen uns etwas hier auf!
Unser Leben geht weiter, Schatz.
Und es wird besser als jemals zuvor!
- Ja, was immer ihr sagt.
- Selma, ich muss dir noch etwas sagen.